TYRA: Previously on
America's Next Top Model,
Michelle opened up
to her roommates.
I might be gay.
TYRA:
But Amanda shut down.
MICHELLE: You're not being
yourself, stupid.
I don't know what to say.
I don't know what to tell you.
TYRA: A red carpet
challenge with Janice
had the girls flustered.
Give me. Give me the mic.
TYRA: At the photo shoot,
Melrose was stunning.
I love what she's doing now.
TYRA: But AJ couldn't
hide her indifference.
That's as far as my face goes.
The judges aren't sure
how much you care.
TYRA:
And this attitude
sent her packing.
( kiss )
TYRA:
Eight girls remain.
Who will be eliminated tonight?
( music playing )
You want to be on top?
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
WOMAN: Did you guys get soda?
I asked for the thin crust.
ANOTHER WOMAN: Deal with it.
EUGENA:
It's been weeks and weeks
that we've been here,
and these girls
are starting to show
their asses.
Jaeda won't stop
complaining about her hair.
CariDee just can't
keep her clothes on,
and I'm tired of hearing
Anchal's complaining.
Melrose is a backstabbing ho.
Damn, gosh!
Ugh.
CARIDEE: There it is.
Poor Anchal, you know,
she's struggling
with her weight.
I think she has
low self-esteem,
which can only be brought up
by herself,
and, you know,
some peer mediation.
Be strong.
ANCHAL: I'm very
in the corner-type person.
I'm so, like,
self-conscious about everything,
especially my body weight,
and it's just
stressing me out.
- Yay!
- You got it!
And I got something.
WOMAN:
She got another package.
BROOKE: I think this is
a theme package 'cause--
for graduation.
My graduation and my prom
are both coming up.
She sent a copy
of my diploma.
I am bummed,
because, you know,
walking the stage is just
one of the ceremonial things.
It's just a ritual.
And I'm not gonna
go through it.
But it's a sacrifice I make,
and I'm so happy here.
MELROSE:
I woke up this morning,
I went in the backyard,
and there's all this
equipment sitting outside.
I'm curious to see
what's gonna happen today.
Hello.
I'm Elyssa.
I'm the photo shoot producer.
I have a little impromptu
photo shoot for you today.
Ooh, yay!
You wanna see
who's photographing you?
Yeah, of course.
Come on out.
MELROSE:
Ah! Yay!
- Melrose! Hi, Melrose!
- Hi!
I'm your photographer
for the day.
- Yes, that's awesome.
- TYRA: Yeah.
I've been doing
photography for about 10 years,
and just playing with it.
Nothing real professional.
I shot a bunch
of friends and stuff.
On season 1 of Top Model,
I shot the finalists.
And, recently,
I shot Nicole Richie.
So I'm gonna shoot you today.
And it's gonna be
black and white and edgy.
And the mood
that I'm looking for is...
angry, almost kind of evil.
But still maintaining
that sex appeal.
- Okay. Cool.
- TYRA: All right.
You're gonna have
these red eye contacts
that are gonna make you
look like the damned.
So we're gonna get you
a little hair and make-up,
but it's only gonna take
three minutes.
MELROSE: Ooh.
I'm so ready.
I'm ready to be scary.
TYRA:
You ready, Melrose?
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo.
Hoo-hoo.
TYRA:
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Getting more tension
in the arms,
kinda...
There you go.
A little bit looking back out
and kind of cast a spell
out there.
Okay.
You can't get away with this
kind of stuff anywhere else.
TYRA: All right, Brooke,
come on down.
Is that okay if I growl?
TYRA: You can do
whatever you want.
Look at me.
Relax your mouth
just a little bit.
BROOKE:
I know that being young
is sometimes
a little bit overwhelming.
I don't have the experience
that these girls have.
Which one do you think
for her lenses?
- MAN: Cat eyes.
- TYRA: Cat.
- MAN: Yeah.
- Oh.
TYRA: Ooh!
I want you think about when
those judges are telling you,
"Girl, your picture sucks!"
Nice. Hold that.
I'm not sure, but I think
we might have got it
on the first shot.
I'm not kidding.
Usually putting on contacts
that I'm able to see better.
Now I see worse.
TYRA: All right.
Bring on Michelle.
Step up to that sandbag.
I need you to think angry.
There you go.
MICHELLE:
How big is the shot?
It's gonna be a beauty shot.
Good questions.
( laughing )
Look like,
"I'm going to bite you."
Really scary,
but don't lose your model.
Like Halloween. Okay?
You got it. That was good.
Ow.
TYRA: Go on in.
JAEDA: It feels so icky.
You have no idea how scary
you look right now.
I'm like, "Jaeda."
JAEDA: I don't really
like looking freaky.
It's not my thing.
I like to be the pretty girl.
( bell dinging )
TYRA: Nice.
How's my focus? Blurry?
Okay. I felt her moving,
and me shaking and me--yeah.
And don't forget your neck.
Relax your face.
Oh, I can't see anything.
( Valente laughs )
I want you to get there
and hold it.
Even more.
Evil.
Okay. Let me test
and make sure we're okay.
So what I saw in your film
is a beautiful girl
that looks nervous
and uncomfortable.
So I don't want you
to second-guess yourself.
I don't want you to go,
"I think this is right.
I think it is."
Just go, "It's right."
Even if it's wrong,
I'm gonna snap it.
- All right.
- Okay?
Now I'm seeing
a confident girl.
( music playing )
I want you to lean forward
and give me some arms.
Separate, chin down.
ANCHAL:
Tyra, all of a sudden,
she's standing
in front of you,
talking to you.
You're kind of just like,
"Whoa."
I'm very nervous
about my photo shoot,
to be honest with you.
- We got it.
- ANCHAL: We got it?
- You sure?
We got it.
Please, make you happy.
( music playing )
CARIDEE:
Sexy scary is fun, you know.
It's dark, it's deep,
but at the same time, it's hot.
- ( growls )
- ( hissing )
CariDee, you are feeling this,
aren't you?
Oh, I love the camera.
I told you that.
MAN:
Turn it up!
CARIDEE: Oh, thank you so much!
That was so fun.
See you later. ( hiss )
CARIDEE: I gotta get back
to normal CariDee.
ANCHAL:
Tyra Mail.
"Ready to flaunt your assets?"
Question, question, question.
"Love, Tyra."
Are we wearing,
like, lingerie?
( music playing )
( burlesque music playing )
( cheering )
Hello, ladies.
ALL:
Hello, Raja.
Welcome to the gorgeous,
historic El Rey Theatre.
You guys know me
as Sutan, typically.
- You look real urban.
- Cool.
I'm my alter ego Raja today.
MICHELLE: We finally
get to see Sutan as Raja,
and he looked great.
Sutan looked friggin'
phenomenal. It was so fun.
We're gonna teach you
a little bit
about the fundamentals,
the 101 on being sexy.
( all cheering )
Now, if you're all ready,
I'd like to introduce you
to my very, very dear friend.
She is a world-renowned
burlesque entertainer.
Please welcome to the stage
the one and only
Dita Von Teese.
MELROSE:
When he said Dita Von Teese,
I'm like, "There's no way.
That woman is so big right now."
She's traveling the world.
SUTAN:
Give it up, everybody.
( burlesque music playing )
I'm thinking, "Dear God,
please don't let our teach
be a striptease."
Because I think
my dad would die.
- Oh, my God.
- All right.
( cheers and applause )
- You ready for your lesson?
- ALL: Yes.
Well, the first thing
I would say is,
you never wanna look like
you're trying too hard.
In burlesque,
using your hips a lot
is really important.
It can be really subtle,
like just popping a little hip.
You don't have to, like,
you know,
do this kind of thing.
And also, like, using props.
They're not your enemy.
They're your friend.
Having something with you
on stage is, like,
it's the best thing.
SUTAN:
So let's start with Anchal.
ANCHAL: After seeing Dita do it,
I really honestly thought,
"I don't wanna go out there.
I really don't wanna dance.
"I'm not--I can't dance.
What are you doing?
Don't throw me up there."
Take yourself to a place
where sunflowers grow.
And what would you be doing
in a field of sunflowers
alone or with your man?
( music playing )
WOMAN:
Go, Anchal.
JAEDA: Lately, Anchal's been
complaining about her weight,
and just really not confident
at all in herself.
DITA:
What I would say about Anchal is
she seemed like
she was a little insecure.
She could work on
feeling a little more confident
and comfortable
about being sexy.
You could've really
utilized this more.
DITA:
You can do whatever you want.
If you were in a photo shoot
and you just suddenly
laid down,
that could've been the shot.
WOMAN:
Whoo! Work it, baby.
MICHELLE:
I don't know what to think.
I mean,
I'm used to being tomboy.
I'm used to being,
you know, athletic.
It's just a weird feeling.
SUTAN: All right.
( music playing )
( cheering )
Whoo!
EUGENA: Melrose is
over-the-top. They said,
"Be subtle. don't be stripper,
and she didn't do it right."
SUTAN: All right. All right.
All right. That's enough.
WOMAN:
Yeah, girl!
CARIDEE: She doesn't show a lot
of emotion, but you can tell
Eugena's got that look
and the body.
There it is!
SUTAN:
Not bad. Good, Eugena.
Actually, I wanna see you do it.
I've never seen you
with pompoms.
Like showing the foot off
and, like, going up your leg.
But you were really good.
JAEDA: It is a lot harder
for me to be sexy,
knowing that I have short hair.
I always worked with my hair.
Like, I'd get it in my face.
( cheers )
DITA:
I think Amanda did a great job.
I think she had a really
great combination
of sexiness and sweetness.
SUTAN:
Good job.
( music playing )
WOMAN:
Whoo!
DITA: Of all the girls,
I think that CariDee could,
you know, take it down
a little bit.
She had on a skirt,
and she was up there
with her legs spread apart.
And I was like,
"Girl, I can see your panties."
( all cheering )
WOMAN:
Awesome.
BROOKE: I have to be
seductive and sexy.
That's not something
I normally am.
I felt totally uncomfortable.
What is that? It's a fan.
You're hot.
There you go.
DITA:
Brooke had a difficult time,
and she seemed the most nervous
of everyone to be sexy.
SUTAN:
You guys have a good time?
ALL:
Yeah!
On your next shoot, perhaps,
think about
how sexy you can be.
You have to walk out there
like you mean it.
And you always
have to feel, like,
you are the best
at what you're doing,
and you have to do everything
with confidence
and not second-guess
yourself.
One more time. Please
give it up to my friend, Dita.
- ( cheering )
- You're awesome!
JAEDA: When I see pictures
and people have
long, luscious hair, I'm like,
"Wow! Long, luscious hair.
It's what I want."
I wasn't even having fun today,
because hair is really
important to a girl.
I've had long hair
my whole life.
I loved my hair.
It gave me a part
of my personality. I know that.
EUGENA: Gosh, it's hair.
You know, you look
ten times better without it.
I don't feel like a woman.
EUGENA: I'll be very glad
to see another person
get out the house,
because less girls,
less confusion.
I'm tired of them.
Tyra Mail!
All right, ladies.
"My mama taught me to
keep my elbows off the table,
but she didn't say
anything about feet."
- WOMAN: Oh!
- "Love, Tyra."
Table dancing!
CATHY: Welcome, ladies.
My name is Cathy Gould,
and I'm the Director
of Elite Model Management.
BROOKE: Cathy is someone
who I've got to impress.
That's my ultimate goal.
I wanna be signed with Elite.
With me tonight
is supermodel Kylie Bax.
Kylie's one of our top models,
who's been seen
in Vogue magazine.
- Hi.
- ALL: Hey.
CATHY:
Tonight, I've decided to throw
a private party.
And guess who's on the menu?
You are.
Behind me is a dining room table
that will turn
into a runway show this evening.
Yesterday,
you learned how to be sexy.
Tonight,
you'll be showing my guests
just how well you can do.
ANCHAL: I'm standing there,
and I'm really freakin' nervous,
because all the girls
have a perfect body.
And I think just having
that perfect body
gives you more confidence.
And my tummy just went, "Grr."
( music playing )
CATHY: I think Eugena
tried too hard
and worked that tray too much.
I was scared
they were gonna fall on us.
They were? I thought that
was her coming out again.
( music playing )
BROOKE:
It's hard being up there,
but I had to focus
the whole time
on staying engaged
and not on how
uncomfortable I was.
( music playing )
CATHY: I think Melrose
did a great job.
Amazing timing,
a lot of confidence,
and it just
looked natural for her.
CATHY:
Anchal does not have
a typical runway body.
( music playing )
CATHY: Ladies,
I think that you all did
a wonderful job tonight.
KYLIE: Cari, your feeling
and your energy was great.
CATHY:
Anchal, for runway,
your body has to be
in a little bit better shape.
ANCHAL:
I'm like, "Crap.
There goes my little
contract with Elite."
CATHY:
Melrose,
I think you had
a great personality
and you had a very nice flow.
KYLIE: Brooke,
you didn't convince me.
I just think you kind of
didn't know what to do
with that scarf.
So, the winner
of the runway show tonight
will receive
an editorial spread
in Seventeen Magazine.
- ALL: Oh.
- And our winner is,
Melrose. So, why
don't you come on over here?
MELROSE: Everyone's gonna
hate on me when I go home.
But that's okay,
because I won a challenge.
I won.
CARIDEE: If she was the best,
then she was the best,
and that's great.
Good for her. She wins again.
You get to pick three friends
that will be
in the shoot with you.
Brooke,
Michelle, and Amanda.
We're gonna be in Seventeen!
EUGENA: Melrose wins
the challenge again,
she goes, "Oh, my God!
Oh, my God! Oh, my God!"
I think it's stupid.
( music playing )
MELROSE: It's kind of ironic
that I'm the oldest one
and I'm doing
the Seventeen Magazine thing.
- Hi!
- Hey, there.
- ALL: Hey.
- I'm Atoosa Rubenstein,
Editor-in-chief
of Seventeen Magazine.
It's great to see
you girls again.
Congratulations, Melrose...
- Thank you.
- ...on winning the challenge.
It's very exciting.
You might remember
Beau Quillian
from cycle 1 of Top Model.
And Jeffrey Jones is our
top, top fashion
photographer at Seventeen.
Basically, what we're
gonna be doing here today
is a shoot
of our October issue
that's about taking
a cute outfit
and making it
a little bit sexy.
JEFFREY:
That's cool, I like that.
- ATOOSA: Perfect.
- MELROSE: I would be happy
to see any girl in this house
on the cover of Seventeen.
I'd be happy just to see myself,
of course.
ATOOSA:
Brooke, you look so gorgeous.
BROOKE:
Today was really comfortable.
I got to play Brooke,
the energetic, bubbly,
happy, smiley girl,
because that's who I am.
Because I know
I have to work on my body.
You already know that.
It's not like I want
to gain more weight.
It's just that I stress out.
I'm tired of people telling me
I can't do it
just because of how
I look or how much I weigh.
CARIDEE:
The whole thing is, though,
it's overeating that gains
weight, you know.
- Right here.
- Right here, too.
CARIDEE: If you concentrate
on eating better,
- you'll feel better.
- It's true.
CARIDEE: And then your body
will follow.
You know, it's your mind first,
mind first.
Cari, I love you.
Having CariDee talk to me
and coach me through this
is helping me a lot.
This will hopefully save me
from elimination.
( music playing )
EUGENA: Tyra Mail.
Tyra Mail.
"He eyed her heaving bosom
"as she strutted down
the catwalk
"while he yearned
for her modelesque,
"yet Rubenesque body.
"He extended his strong
manly hand.
"It brushed it against
her supple skin.
"She moaned in ecstasy,
"and then left the crowd aghast
"into the dark of the night.
Love, Tyra."
JAEDA:
Where's that fan, girl?
EUGENA:
Good morning.
- ALL: Whoo!
- JAY: Yo, yo!
So, what did you guys learn
about this week?
ALL:
Being sexy.
There's a fine line between
being sexy and sleazy.
Models shoot
all sorts of covers.
So, today, you girls
are actually shooting
the covers of romance novels.
( all cheering )
MELROSE:
The image that you get
when you hear
romance novel is like,
groping, you know,
really aggressive,
like, painting.
JAY: When you're on the
cover of a romance novel,
you draw the viewer in.
You've got to have that story
in your mind, and, trust me,
I got a story for each and every
one of you this morning.
Jaeda, we are gonna
have this whole
Dracula scene going on.
ALL:
Oooh.
JAY:
Eugena, secret lovers
caught in the act.
Michelle,
you're gonna have
a secret love child.
CariDee, peasant in love
with a rich man.
Melrose, one of these madams
in a brothel.
AMANDA:
Oh, I'm so jealous.
JAY: Amanda, you're gonna be
the other woman
leaving your man
for another woman.
All right, Anchal, we are
gonna make you Cleopatra.
WOMAN: Whoo!
JAY:
Brooke, you're so desperate
for your man to stay 'cause
he's trying to leave you.
Oh, no.
So there's a lot
to have fun with.
I want to introduce you
to your photographer.
Her name's Randee.
Randee, come out here.
- How are you?
- ALL: Hey.
RANDEE: Hi. Well,
he pretty much explained
what you're gonna do.
- It sounds like fun, right?
- ALL: Yeah.
And wait till you meet
your co-star,
because he's someone who knows
all about romance
novel covers.
( screaming )
BROOKE:
Jay tells us, "I want you
to meet your guest star
for the photo shoot."
And I'm thinking, "All right,
"you know, someone young, hot.
Let's get some testosterone
over here."
JAY:
Come on out, girls.
FABIO:
Hi, guys.
Oh, Fabio!
Come down.
CARIDEE:
Yeah! I was like,
"Oh, my God. Are you serious?"
Like, they definitely got
all the love icons
of all love icons.
- I'm Brooke.
- Nice to meet you, Brooke.
JAY:
This man knows about
selling romance cover.
EUGENA:
All I can remember growing up
is seeing him on
all these romance novel covers
with his shirt open
and kissing these women
and feeling up on them.
We're gonna have a good shoot?
- Yeah.
- CARIDEE: Hell, yeah.
JAY:
All right, CariDee.
RANDEE: Aw, it's
the little peasant girl.
JAY: Open yourself up, like,
almost look away like,
"Oh, I don't know if I can."
Ugh.
"Oh, I can't."
CARIDEE: I was trying
really hard to be sexy,
but not sleazy.
JAY: Oh, that looks like
Nicole Kidman right there.
Does it not?
FABIO:
CariDee was brilliant.
She's very sexy, she knows
how to pose in front
of the camera.
- JAY: Damn.
- Yay. That was fun.
JAY:
It was beyond orgasmic.
I go to another level.
AMANDA: It's kind of a
confusing character for me.
I don't know how
I'm gonna get into it.
JAY: It's like
it's tearing you apart
to leave him.
I need to believe that.
FABIO:
Amanda, she has
a great look
and great potential.
But I thought
she was kind of nervous.
JAY: What are you thinking
about, Amanda?
He's my boyfriend.
I want to
see more excitement.
Amanda's been consistently fair.
It's not bad, it's not good.
It's just average.
So you're inseparable, huh?
- No.
We're very separable.
MICHELLE:
You ever wished you had a twin?
JAY: This is a more
intimate scene,
so it's like, you know,
that kind of personal space
- that we all have around us?
- MICHELLE: Our bubble?
Our little bubble.
That bubble is burst.
MICHELLE: I'm trying to get
into the whole family scene,
being, like, a couple.
I've actually never
been in a relationship,
so lying in bed with a man
and a baby
is kind of different for me.
RANDEE: Michelle,
chin up a little bit.
MICHELLE: It was fun and
uncomfortable at the same time.
And my body
was kind of awkward.
Look what I'm doing.
My hand's here.
But you're doing this.
I'm doing this.
Do you see what I'm saying?
It's a little more delicate.
JAY: Michelle is usually
very good on set.
Her face was good,
but her body
was extremely uncomfortable.
You know the competition's
only getting tougher.
- Yeah.
- And all the judges
are gonna do
are look at the photos.
Who's engaging themself?
Who isn't?
ANCHAL: This photo shoot
is very important,
and I can't let my shyness
or my low self-esteem
get in the way
and just make me be like,
"Oh, no, I don't
wanna do this."
RANDEE: Lean back,
just let it go. Gorgeous.
ANCHAL: I wasn't really
thinking about my weight.
I'm just like, "You know what?
I'll use my sexy, demure
to help me
in this photo shoot."
JAY:
Ooh, that's pretty.
- That's it.
- ANCHAL: Got it?
- Yes.
- Thank you.
JAY: Anchal just grabbed
the bull by the horns,
and I think that's why
it worked.
It's beautiful, because
you let yourself go,
and it's great.
She's natural.
She takes direction very well.
She's very sexy.
She was totally believable.
JAY:
Okay, good job.
Have you ever been
a secret lover?
Yes.
You have been a secret lover.
Ooh, I like that.
Have fun with it.
You don't wanna
lose your neck.
You know how Miss J.
feels about no-neck monsters.
Ooh, I don't like it.
RANDEE:
It's awkward there, right?
And, Eugena, don't rest
your hand on his thigh.
This is a secret moment,
secret lover.
You wouldn't rest your hand.
You'd be grabbing, honey.
Eugena was kind of working
on a three-quarter tank of gas.
And you need to step
in and say,
"I'm a little
uncomfortable here,
but I'm gonna go
for this 150%."
JAEDA: My story is the girl
who falls in love
with a vampire
and gets bitten.
RANDEE: It's real sexy,
and you're giving in.
Jaeda you can grab him.
He has just romanced you.
He's wooed you.
You're not dead yet.
So don't
just hang there limp.
JAEDA: I really need
to get in this.
I really need to get going
in this competition.
RANDEE:
That's beautiful right there.
JAY:
Last frame.
JAEDA:
I think it went pretty well.
I think my shoot
went really well.
- Thank you so much.
- Very good.
JAEDA: I bet you have girls
at your house all the time, huh?
FABIO:
No, I'm a virgin.
Oh, I'm sure!
BROOKE:
Are you a virgin, Fabio?
- Of course. You didn't know?
- I am too man.
- FABIO: You, too?
- BROOKE: Yeah.
FABIO: My God, there's
still a virgin in Texas?
BROOKE:
Yes.
I walk into the room,
and I am a little bit nervous,
to be perfectly honest.
JAY: You're kind of like
digging into it
- like a claw.
- Okay.
JAY: I want you
to just hold on to him.
His thighs are so big.
Well, he's got big thighs.
I mean, hey.
BROOKE:
Fabio is not only tall,
he is thick as a tree.
- Okay, um, Brooke?
- Yes.
Put your hand up higher.
Like you're trying
to find some calm.
Like, "Okay.
He's not gonna leave me.
He's not gonna leave me."
BROOKE:
It's hard because here I am
basically growing up
and being forced
into adulthood, you know.
RANDEE:
Don't wrinkle your forehead.
MELROSE: Brooke is going
through a lot of battles
that almost-18-year-olds
go through with themselves
and leaving home and, like,
trying to figure
themselves out.
JAY: Right now,
you're going, "Ugh!"
as it's, like, looking like
Chunksville in here.
FABIO: Brooke, you can tell
she's a little inexperienced.
She's very young,
so, you know,
you have to give her some time.
Last frame.
- Hello.
- JAY: Melrose.
RANDEE:
Look at her.
JAY:
Come over here, darling.
Great, Melrose.
MELROSE:
My photo shoot goes well.
I just hop
on Fabio's lap, you know.
I just fell in love.
I think he's having the time
of his life tonight.
I mean, what guy wouldn't?
JAY:
That's beautiful.
- Oh my God.
- Wow.
FABIO: I can't believe
I get paid for this.
You know, this is fun.
JAY:
Reach in and push it--Yes.
Push his--Yes,
there you go.
Last frame.
I think everybody needs
a cup of cold water.
Are you coming with me?
No, he is not coming with you.
Ciao, bello.
( music playing )
MICHELLE:
Tyra Mail!
"Tomorrow, you will meet
with the judges.
Only seven will continue on
in the hopes of becoming
American's Next Top Model."
ALL:
"Love, Tyra."
My high school graduation
is during panel
tomorrow night.
I decorated my whole little
corner so pretty like.
WOMAN:
Congrats, grad.
BROOKE:
If I get sent home
on the night of my graduation,
that's going to suck a lot.
If the Director of Elite
is the guest judge,
I'm screwed,
because she obviously
doesn't like my body type.
And, yeah, I'm pretty nervous.
( music playing )
TYRA:
Hello, everybody.
ALL:
Hello.
Another week
and another cut.
And you know
about our prizes.
The first is a modeling contract
with one of the top
modeling agencies in the world,
Elite Model Management,
a cover and six-page spread
of Seventeen Magazine,
and a $100,000 contract
with what? CoverGirl.
All right, it's time
to introduce the judges.
The first is the lovely
Nigel Barker.
I certainly like
an introduction like that.
Your runway diva coach
extraordinaire,
Miss J. Alexander.
What is inspiring this today?
Looks like a bird of paradise.
Darling,
I am a bird of paradise.
TYRA: Ohh!
Twiggy,
legendary fashion icon.
And Cathy Gould,
the Director
of Elite Model Management.
This is the lady to impress.
All right,
so this week you learned
all about how to be sexy
and how to not be
too sexy.
It's time to start
our individual evaluations.
And, Anchal, you're first.
All right, Anchal,
so you had a photo shoot
with me as the photographer
where you had to be sensual,
but spooky and scary
all wrapped into one.
So let's see your best shot.
TWIGGY: I think that's really
a frightening photograph.
Well, you've taken
my breath away.
TYRA:
In photographing you, Anchal,
I thought you committed,
but it is important
to not rest on the make-up
and to take it a step further.
- Got it.
- TYRA: You had a photo shoot
where you were
on the cover with
Mr. Romance Novel himself,
- Fabio.
- Oh!
TYRA:
Love Pyramid, baby.
J:
"I asked you not to do that.
I asked you
to fetch it."
( laughter )
CATHY: I think she looks
in control of him,
and I think that's a...
big accomplishment
for a young model.
One thing in your film is,
it still got
a little hoochie for me.
So you need to learn
how to back the booty up
and not make it hoochie.
You were doing this.
Hey.
WOMAN:
That's so her.
TYRA: Anchal, you know,
you can back the booty up
and still make it fashion.
- All right, Anchal. Thank you.
- Thank you.
TYRA: All right,
up next is Amanda.
Hello, Amanda.
TWIGGY: That could be
from a high-fashion
glossy magazine.
I just love it.
TYRA:
Sexy is not one thing,
and it's something that
I'm constantly teaching
all of you every single week.
That sexy doesn't mean.
And what I love
about your picture is that
it makes you think of sexy
in a different way.
I think you did
a really good job.
TYRA: Amanda, do you remember
when we were first shooting
and I said, you know,
"Relax, put your arms up,
do certain things."
And you would go, like that.
I don't want you to go,
"I think this is right."
Even if it's wrong,
I'm gonna snap it.
Once we had that conversation,
and I picked
that camera back up,
you were a totally
a different person.
So you had a photo shoot
with the lovely Fabio,
"The Other Woman."
TWIGGY: Your innocence
in this, to me, is very sexy.
You little hussy.
Her "other woman" story
is a little deeper.
AMANDA:
I'm the other woman,
but I'm also leaving him
for another woman.
TWIGGY:
Oh, you double little hussy.
Thank you.
Up next, CariDee.
You had a photo shoot
where I photographed you,
and let's see your best shot.
NIGEL: Sort of sexiness
in an Exorcist kind of way.
TWIGGY:
It's a really good photo, Tyra.
TYRA:
Thank you. When I shot you,
you blew me away.
You commit...
in a way that is insane to me.
She would do this thing, like,
turn really, like,
toward me and then turn away,
then turn toward me
and make these noises.
I was growling.
I was like, "Rrr!"
( hissing )
I was wishing that
you were there, actually,
to experience it and to see it
as a real photographer.
- I love that.
- TYRA: You were giving it.
All I had to do
was point and click.
I don't know if I've ever
seen a model do that before.
- Really?
- Mm-mmm.
And I've been doing this
for over a half my life.
- Wow.
- All right, CariDee,
so you had a photo shoot
with Fabio.
Well, let's see your best shot.
"But...I Love Her."
He's a rich man, and
she's just scrubbing the floors.
CATHY: It's a great
beauty shot for you.
- Thank you.
- You often look
very in control
in your photographs.
There's a soft side
that I haven't seen before,
which is very, very nice.
NIGEL: CariDee, you look
absolutely stunning tonight.
I'm just concerned about
the amount of make-up
you're wearing.
TYRA: Its makes you
not look like a model.
What we say every week,
when you retire,
you take all the make-up
on the whole counter,
and you put it
all on your face.
But until that day,
you need to keep it
nice and simple.
- Definitely.
- TYRA: All right,
up next is Brooke.
TWIGGY: I think this is
a very interesting shot,
because you look very young,
which is excellent.
TYRA:
You were really going for it.
It's interesting because
there's these two people.
There's this newscaster girl
that's like,
"Yes, Tyra. Yes, I do agree
"that the weather
is going to be, you know,
70% the chance of rain.
Ooh!"
And then you get on set,
and you get into this thing.
I'm like, "Where is that?"
Because it comes out.
All right, so you had
a photo shoot with Fabio.
"Don't Leave Me!"
NIGEL: As a long shot,
this is fantastic.
TWIGGY:
I'd like to see a close-up.
J: You don't have any
expression in your eyes,
any expression
in your face, nowhere.
I think the angle
is really wrong for you.
TWIGGY:
I love that you're frowning.
It's lovely.
You got into the story.
- TYRA: All right, Brooke.
- BROOKE: Thank you, guys.
TYRA:
You're welcome. Up next is...
Michelle.
You took a chance, Miss Thing.
NIGEL:
She looks like a man-eater.
CATHY: I think this is one
of the best pictures we've seen.
TYRA: And you did so many
other shots that were safe.
I pulled one of those,
and that was your final shot.
And at the last minute,
I changed it,
because it's
very important for me
to give credit to a girl
for doing something
and stepping out of the box.
You had a photo shoot,
and here is your best shot.
"Who's My Baby's Daddy?"
So he went off to war,
and he came
back two years later,
and she had a baby.
Michelle, going
through your film,
you were very,
very uncomfortable.
MICHELLE: I think it's probably
because I've never laid in bed
with another person maybe.
TYRA: I was modeling
when I was 15 years old,
- and I was a virgin.
- Me, too.
TYRA:
And I knew how to go.
There's no excuse
for not having the touch
that you don't know
how to do something.
You've also never been
an evil person.
You've never been
to a black hair fashion show,
and you've never
been hopefully
- a bulimic...
- No.
TYRA: But you can convincingly
did all of those things.
So there's no excuse for saying
that you've
never done something.
Thanks, Michelle.
Up next is Eugena.
Nice and straight hair,
that's pretty.
Thank you.
NIGEL: This shot,
even with contact lenses,
has the strongest eyes
I've ever seen you produce
in a picture.
J:
Because that's really her.
Underneath all this madness,
she's really that evil.
TYRA: What was going
through your mind that day?
Maybe I was mad that day.
NIGEL: When someone
asks you a question,
think about your answer
and deliver an answer
- that we're gonna appreciate.
- TYRA: Yeah, and be likable,
'cause right now
you're not likable.
I try to be myself,
and it comes off
as something else.
CATHY: Is this something
that you have passion for?
- Yes, it is.
- You don't convince me
that you really,
really want this.
TYRA:
Last week, a girl went home
that we felt didn't want this,
and that's what
we feel from you,
and it's hard because
you're stuck inside of yourself,
and you're talking,
and you don't know that
you're going like this
when you're talking.
You don't see
what you're giving off.
- Have manners.
- TWIGGY: And charm.
So you had a photo shoot,
and here's your best shot.
"Oh No You Didn't!"
NIGEL:
Oh, yes, she did.
You know what, this shot
works as a long shot,
because you've got
a great body,
and it's a nice picture.
As a close-up,
I don't believe anything
in your eyes.
TYRA: Whatever you were
thinking when I shot you,
you gotta bring that.
- All right. Thanks, Eugena.
- Thank you.
All right,
up next is Melrose.
You were challenge winner,
so congratulations.
Thank you.
Here's your best shot.
TWIGGY: I'll tell you.
Today, you've--for me,
given the best photographs.
TYRA:
Your film was beautiful,
but if you take
the dark make-up off
and the contacts,
it looked like an ad for a--
for a cosmetics line.
I wasn't feeling
what I know you could bring.
All right, Melrose, you
had a photo shoot with Fabio,
and here's your best shot.
"Lady of the Night."
- CATHY: I think it's great.
- NIGEL: I do, too.
I think this is
the best shot of the bunch.
This is an obvious sexuality.
- Right.
- TYRA: This is easy.
You know how to do this.
Work on the other stuff.
Be in the mirror tonight.
Up next is Jaeda.
Are you ready to see
your picture?
NIGEL: There's something
about this shot
which is a look
that I haven't seen in you.
Whatever fear you have,
you brought this
to this picture.
TYRA:
Jaeda, you were giving me looks,
and, you know,
they were okay,
but then you did this
for, like, four frames,
and I felt the picture happen.
NIGEL: But right now,
you look terrified again.
TYRA: You feel like
you might go home?
I've been
in the bottom two a lot,
so I really need
to step it up.
TWIGGY: Well, I think that photo
stepped it up,
but as Nigel says, you gotta
give us a bit more enthusiasm
in this end.
- J: Inspire us.
- All right, Jaeda, so let's see
your romance novel cover.
J: So "Nibble in the Night."
TYRA:
So he was a vampire.
JAEDA: I felt his breath
every second.
I was like, "Aah."
Listen, love,
when you're in modeling,
you've gotta get
into character.
It shows that you
obviously didn't like him
being that close.
CATHY: I think she has a fear
that every week
she's gonna be dropped,
and she's beautiful.
You keep on thinking
you're gonna go home,
finally the judges will be like,
"She thinks she going home,
so let's send her home."
So the more you think it,
the more we think it.
- Okay.
- Thanks, Jaeda.
All right.
Now, it's time for the judges
to decide who's going home.
And when I call you back,
I'll announce
who that person is.
All right.
So now, it's time to decide
who's going home.
- Brooke.
- TWIGGY: Well, for me,
Brooke's just gets
better and better.
Guys, I'm still getting
such a pageant feel
from Brooke.
CATHY: I agree with you.
I think she seems
more like a beauty queen.
Anchal.
CATHY:
She's exotic and sexy.
TYRA:
This picture of Anchal is
probably one of my favorite
in the bunch.
But she's almost too pretty,
and those are all the things
that you wanna hear as a model.
Pretty, bone structure,
symmetry,
but she might have too much.
Or doesn't what to do
with too much.
TYRA: Amanda.
She's not classically pretty
when you stare at her.
- J: Mm-mmm.
- NIGEL: Amanda has risen now.
I think this is
her defining moment.
When I was shooting her,
she was so
second-guessing herself,
but then I told her,
"Snap out of it!"
and she snapped out of it.
Jaeda.
NIGEL:
Fabio is overpowering her.
She doesn't look like a model.
She just looks like an extra.
In this photo, she's looking
as though she's saying,
"I'll be damned if I'm gonna be
at the bottom two
again this week."
TYRA: I don't understand
how you can
get such a strong picture
and such a weak picture...
- TWIGGY: I agree.
- ...in the same week.
CariDee.
TWIGGY:
I love her hands.
I love
her whole body language.
She tries too hard
to be a model all the time.
TYRA: I agree with you, Cathy.
I feel like
she's a little too eager.
There's a difference between
desire and desperation.
Eugena.
NIGEL: She's got to work
on that attitude.
It's just like,
honey, get with the program.
TYRA: I'm very impressed
by her in this photo,
but I can't follow her
on every single photo shoot.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, she's gotta bring this
all the time.
Melrose.
TYRA: Melrose does not know
how to do
weird, freaky, I don't know.
She kept smiling
when I was shooting her.
J:
Well, maybe with Melrose,
she's just more comfortable
being the lady of the night.
- CATHY: Yes.
- Michelle.
TWIGGY:
I think she's very fashion.
You know what, for me,
this is the weakest week
for Michelle.
I'm not buying it.
TYRA: I'm always very
frustrated with girls
like give excuses for things,
like when she said
that she'd never
cuddled before.
There are so many
things these girls
haven't done
in this competition.
J:
Who the baby daddy?
You're the baby's daddy.
I the baby daddy.
( music playing )
TYRA: Eight beautiful girls
stand before me,
but I only have seven photos
in my hands.
And these photos represent
the seven of you that will
still be in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
The first name that
I'm going to call is...
Amanda.
Miss Most Improved.
You were struggling
throughout this competition,
but you've come
and pushed through.
Congratulations.
You're still in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Thank you.
The next name
that I'm going to call.
CariDee.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
- Anchal.
- Yeah.
Anchal, this picture
is absolutely beautiful.
Your other picture
But until now,
all we've seen in your photos
is your self-doubt.
So you need to bring
this confidence,
not just this week,
but every week.
Congratulations.
The next name that
I'm going to call is...
Melrose.
Congratulations.
You're still in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Thank you so much.
Jaeda.
I wanna commend you,
'cause you just walked up here
like you deserve to be here.
You know what
I'm talking about?
You feel good?
You're still in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
The next name
that I'm going to call is...
Michelle.
You're Miss Excuses.
"I've never done that.
I've never been cuddled."
No more excuses, Michelle.
Congratulations.
You're still in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
Okay.
Will Brooke and Eugena
please step forward?
I only have one photo
in my hands.
And this photo
represents the girl
that will still be
in the running towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
I will call only one name,
and the girl
that I do not call
must immediately
return to the house,
pack your belongings,
and go home.
Both of you stand before me
for very different reasons.
One of you, the judges
love her personality,
but the judges continue to say,
"Has she lasted this long
because she's so bubbly,
or is she here
because she has
the potential to be a model?"
And one girl stands before me
with obvious potential
to be a model.
What we're looking
for is something called
humility and respect.
So we have to see it Eugena.
( music playing )
TYRA:
Congratulations.
You're still in the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
( crying ) It's my friggin'
high school graduation.
I love you guys.
TYRA: Oh, Brooke,
one thing I heard you say.
You said that you could be
at graduation right now,
and there's a lot
of girls graduating,
and they're walking,
but do you know how many of them
would love to be
in your place right now?
BROOKE: I know.
This is where I'd rather be.
TYRA:
You graduated.
You just missed
the ceremony, Brooke.
I have high hopes for you.
I just didn't see
this one coming...
at all.
I gave everything up
to come here,
and ironically enough,
this is the night
that I get chosen to go home.
I wouldn't do it differently
for any amount of money
in the world for anything.
I've experienced a whole lot
while I've been here,
and I have grown up, you know.
I'm not gonna go back
a high school senior anymore.
I'm gonna go back an adult.
( music playing )
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪